welcome everyone I usually say welcome
to the Jackson Institute but we're
actually in Luce Hall today
so thank you to the Macmillan Center for
hosting us given the size of this crowd
I'm Ted Witten Steen deputy director for
leadership programs here at Jackson this
talk on China versus USA a battle for
Africa's future is one that's rather
timely and we're delighted to be joined
by calling Coleman one of our most
recent senior fellows here at the
Jackson Institute this spring and I
believe many of you know my colleague
Eddie manned Ria's well director for
Africa here Niels in Office of
International Affairs one of the key
drivers of the Yale Africa initiative of
Yale president salva Eddie was with
president salva in Nigeria just over
winter break
colin comes to us to yale and to the
jackson institute with extraordinary
experience across the continent at the
highest levels of thinking regarding
economics governance statecraft on the
continent he teaches here this semester
in the graduate seminar also with the
Yale School of Management on Africa
doing business in the last frontier of
global Glo growth as many of you know he
was CEO of sub-saharan Africa for
goldman sachs he headed up the firm's
south africa alphys since 2000 and
really has won numerous awards and
accolades for his business leadership
prior to that he was a renowned
anti-apartheid activist in South Africa
during its transition to democracy he's
someone who has seen firsthand the
growth of Chinese investment and related
influence on the African continent
commensurate with Chinese rise to great
power status on the world stage and so
he's exceptionally well equipped to help
us decipher some of the broader economic
and geopolitical forces taking shape on
this issue that many of you have seen in
headline news so without further ado let
me just thank Colin welcome him to the
Jackson Institute NT Yale thank Eddie
for joining us
Caan has some prepared remarks and after
which Eddie will moderate a conversation
with him and with you in the audience
and so copies of the remarks will also
be made electronically available to
those who were registered for the talk
after the factor if you're interested in
getting a copy we'll add you to that
list as well so I'll stop now and just
say Thank You Colin for joining us so
it's a real pleasure
[Applause]
thanks so much it's an honor and a
privilege to be at the Sistema
institution Yale University talking to
you on this wonderful subject and I'm
pleased to say that many of my students
are in the in the audience and so I feel
a lot of pressure because they are
extremely brilliant and I know I will be
grilled in the next class about what I'm
going to say I'd also say my label pin
for those who can see it which is the
United States flag next to the South
African flag is not a expression of my
bias it's on this particular topic at
all and for those in the Chinese from
the Chinese side of the audience I have
as Ted indicated spent a lot of time in
China probably 15 trips over a 10-year
period starting in 2007 which led up to
the ICBC investment in Standard Bank at
the end of 2007 and beginning of 2008
which started my interest in China and
was followed by other transactional
experiences I had including john chauhan
buying metrics which is a Zambian copper
and TRC copper asset listed on the
China's Berg Stock Exchange and helping
discovery the South African insurance
health insurance company former joint
venture with ping'an a few years later
so I've had the fortune of the good
fortune of having firsthand
experience and getting to know the
Chinese quite well in a recent article a
published called called Africa is the
last frontier for global growth argued
that today
Africa accounts for 17% of the world's
population but only 3% of global GDP and
that represented both an opportunity and
a threat the opportunity is of vast
economic growth offering investors
massive absolute opportunity in the
demographic dividend but at the same
time it represents a threat and the
threat is of potential extremism global
instability arising from the source of
this disparity between our high
contribution to population and a low
level of resources in the world and I
did argue there that if Africa sustains
and accelerates the structural economic
reforms it could emulate China's rapid
rise of the last 50 years but success is
far from guaranteed and failure would
have grave and global consequences in
fact this research I did for this paper
drew a far greater level of concern as I
studied the projections of global growth
and the projections of global population
formation the IMF today estimates
today's GDP at 87 trillion of which the
United States represents twenty one
point four trillion and China fourteen
point one all of Africa's GDP
contributes only two point six trillion
dollars demonstrating just how tiny
Africa's economy is in the overall
global economy today
the 2019 United Nations report called
world population prospects on which I
based much of this population projection
suggests that due to high fertility
gains in life expectancy and declines in
child mortality by 2001 Africa Africans
will comprise 4.3 billion out of the
then ten point nine billion of the world
population or 39 percent of the global
population in other words two in five
Africans by the year two and five of the
world's population will be Africans by
the Year 2060 so in 2100 this represents
as a dichotomy between global growth and
population contribution and potential
impending and grave humanitarian crisis
this wrong way relationship what I call
at this equilibrium between an
underweight share of global GDP and an
outside share of global population
foretells an inevitably damned future of
poverty urban decay hunger chaos and
extreme streamer's 'm and less growth
can be spurred at higher levels in
Africa so Africa needs to urgently
accelerate structural economic reforms
and find ways of achieving higher growth
rates so if one imagines how will this
be achieved and how will we achieve a
greater share of global growth in order
to close the gap with popov the share of
population so I computed for the next 40
years if you were to first double in the
first twenty the share of GDP to six
percent and then double it again in the
following 20 to 12 percent that would
working back require Africa to
effectively compound its annual average
growth rate by six percent per annum to
achieve that
and Africa in the last 20 years achieved
5% growth since the Millennium so it
certainly reforms a stretched target and
would would be possible but there are
many forces that I'll talk about that
will make it very very challenging for
Africa to achieve it but should it
achieve it the flip of that coin the
flip side of the coin is that it
represents an opportunity to grow
Africa's economy in those 40 years from
the two point six trillion by 24
trillion in the next forty years or six
hundred billion dollars per annum now a
six hundred billion dollar per annum
growth if it's achieved would represent
one of the greatest economic value ad
opportunities for the world and
obviously for investors and markets
represents an outstanding opportunity
which forms the basis of multinationals
sovereign wealth funds investors and
others looking at the opportunity in
Africa with investing eyes these
calculations imply that Africa's GDP
would go to 26 trillion 26 and a half
trillion dollars a huge economic leap
forward but even if realized we would
still not completely close the gap
between population share of the world
and GDP and by 2060 with this stretch
target being achieved you would then
have 28 percent of the world's
population sharing 12 only 12 percent of
the world's GDP so imagine if there is a
failure to achieve that growth what the
then situation would look like and risks
to growth for costs for the region or
skewed to the downside if African
economies falter on a GDP per capita
basis Africa will get poorer and be the
both the largest regional contributor
and concentration of poverty in the
world
therefore for greater domestic and
regional economic discipline and
seamless execution of structural
economic reforms will be required to
lift Africa therefore as we start to
think about the contribution of China
and the United States Africa's challenge
is really a global challenge and in my
estimation one of the least understood
and one of the greatest challenges of
the 21st century so let's look at China
in the United States and the strategies
for Africa I was very fortunate to be at
the Great Hall of the People in Beijing
on September 3rd 2018 as part of the
South African delegation to the then
folk' conference the forum on China
Africa core cooperation and to witness
President Xi Jinping deliver what was
the standard-bearer speech for China
about the strategy for Africa we have
also read the ambassador Bolton
announcement in December 2018 of prosper
Africa which was formally launched in
Mozambique in June 2019 and these two
statements represent effectively the
strictest strategy platforms of the
respective countries so what did
President Xi Jinping have to say firstly
very I would say very smartly in
rebuttal of the criticisms of the China
approach he laid out of what he called a
five no approach no interference in
African countries pursuit of development
pods are quotes no interference in
international into internal affairs no
imposition of our will on African
countries no attachment of political
strings to assistance and no seeking of
selfish political gains in investment
and financing cooperation with Africa in
other words he was underlining that he
understands and China understands the
platform criticisms of the Chinese
approach he then announced eight
initiatives to be
Menten supported by a sixty billion
dollar package of financing over a
three-year period this is the second
three-year sixty billion dollar period
that he announced starting in 2015 and
those eight were industrial promotion
infrastructure cooperation trade
facilitation green development capacity
building health care people-to-people
exchange and peace and security and each
one was a very detailed set of specific
initiatives they were going to undertake
such as specific numbers of people being
sent to China and exchanges specific
numbers of export processing zones they
were going to build specific numbers of
students that were going to go on
exchange programs and so on and so forth
in a very clear program of various forms
of financing including grants equity
loans low-interest loans concessional
finance development finance equity funds
and infrastructure funds the strategy is
are now not new but the tone and depth
of the commitments are comprehensive in
scope and backed by the full might of
the Chinese state including the
state-owned enterprises and again here I
stayed over excuse me
for talks with the Chinese state-owned
enterprises in every single chairman or
CEO of the Chinese state-owned
enterprises attended the meetings and
indicated their personal commitment to
participating in the strategy it is
apparent that China has driven both by
its own economic and diplomatic
objectives to secure political influence
one example of which he is seeking
support by the 53 African voting nations
of the United Nations for the China
Taiwan policy resources such as food
minerals crude oil markets and other
markets but has also taken a position
growing Africa is in the interests of
global peace and prosperity and
represents of an understanding of the
vast opportunity a great economic leap
forward would offer to the Chinese to
capitalize on Africa's growth on the
United States side the prison Trump
administration announced prosper Africa
as a initiative whose goal is to quote
unquote substantially increase two-way
trade and investment we in the United
States and Africa and the response quote
provides a one-stop shop that makes the
full range of those services available
with if you go to the prosper Africa
website it links you to about eight or
nine different institutions plus
departments of state which effectively
provides this tool for African and US
corporations to access the united states
system and so is a kind of a network
around the african opportunity and
that's what they're trying to achieve
through this one-stop shop
unveiling the prosper Africa policy in
November 13 2008 een Ambassador John
Bolton said in a quote the strategy
addresses three core US interests on the
continent first advancing US trade and
commercial ties with the nations across
the region
second countering the threat from
radical Islamic terrorism and violent
conflict third to ensure that US
taxpayers dollars for aid
are used efficiently and effectively in
their article April 2019 called u.s.
economic engagement in Africa
the authors render and board era in
assessing prosper Africa argued that I
quote this initiative risks being a
statement of good intentions with no
teeth or edits of resources but later in
June that year when it was formally
launched there was a turbocharged
provided to prosper Africa in the form
of a relaunching of OPEC under the
agency now
International Development Finance
Corporation or DFC to replace OPEC with
a commitment by the US government to
double OPEX financing availability and
therefore provided something of an
injection of financial backing into the
prosper Africa initiative but clearly
this has to stand as you know offset
against the 60 billion dollars over
three years of the Chinese and will
we'll get to describe shortly
what's the two are actually doing on
trade investment FDI and so on what was
also significant is that OPEX
traditional role was in debt and the DFC
was provided with scope to provide
limited equity investments technical
assistance and oversight on private
sector led development projects we'll
come back shortly to an assessment of
the prosper Africa initiative with
respect to China and us's activities in
Africa today it may surprise many who
have a preconceived idea that the u.s.
is not present at all in Africa and is
no match for the Chinese that the battle
between the United States and China is
not as fought one-sided as first may
appear not as one-sided as first may
appear on trade China supports the
United States as Africa's largest
trading partner in 2009 man much of this
had to do with the us effectively
supplying its own oil production locally
and therefore cutting its reliance on
oil from Africa Chinese two-way trade
with Africa is approximately three times
that now of the United States at 148
billion versus 55 billion of the United
States China is a destination for around
16 percent of sub-saharan Africa's
exports and around 21 percent of the
region's imports the eligibility and
qualifying criteria
for participation in a Goa and the u.s.
generalized system of preferences has
been the subject of some tension most
recently with South Africa as an example
and would effectively its critics say
mark an indication that the United
States is transactional in his approach
rather than long-term relationship
geared a standard bank report inside
China noted that Chinese goods have
penetrated markets deeply increasing
from three percent of Africa's total
imports in 2001 to 19 percent currently
in summary the Chinese have an
undisputed lead over the United States
today in respective African trade
however a goer there remains a strong
weapon in the hands of the world's most
powerful economy on earth in respect of
development and infrastructure funding
China is fun to finance more than three
thousand large infrastructure projects
extending more than eighty six billion
dollars in low-interest rate commercial
loans to Africa between 2000 and 2014 an
average in that period of six billion
dollars per annum this actually compares
as underweight against the nine billion
dollars of annual average foreign aid
which is official development aid by the
US government in Africa over the last
decade in 2015 China pledged to further
sixty billion dollars in loans which
President Xi in Beijing claimed had been
delivered or arranged and I must say as
a note one of the things is very
difficult doing this research is is the
data is very opaque so when it's claimed
to be arranged or delivered it's not
really on record and there's no clear
database to be neutral as between the
Chinese and the United States is what
the vast amount of money is actually
being spent on on the ground
but this represents a ramping up of
funding to 20 billion dollars per annum
which President Xi recommitted to in
September 2008 so while it's difficult
to compare the nine billion dollars of
Oda by the United States to the six
billion dollars in the 2000 to 2014
period China now appears to have ramped
up its development funding hugely to 20
billion dollars per annum on a sustained
basis therefore now outstripping the
united states funding sources in both
size and impact and remember from my
travels around Africa you know you don't
go to any real any really any country
without a stadium and the airport being
built by the Chinese without the roads
being built by the Chinese without the
dams and the power plants effectively in
some relationship with the host
governments of those countries being
driven by the Chinese and significant
numbers met some estimate as much as a
million Chinese living in Africa
increasingly marrying locally and
becoming local Africans on foreign
direct investment the picture is firmly
in the united states way the United
States has shown to be the largest
investor in Africa in variety of studies
in the period 2003 to 2015 US FDI
foreign direct investment average annual
flow was about three and a half billion
dollars in China only 2.2 billion and I
think President Xi Jinping when you look
at what he said in September 2018 picks
up on this because he implores
quote-unquote Chinese companies to make
at least 10 billion dollars of
investment in Africa in the next three
years close quotes taking that up closer
to the US levels from an investment
banking point of view with my history I
looked at what the FDI transactions by
Chinese and US investor have been with a
combined value of weather with a value
of more than a billion dollars per
transaction
and there were five combined value of
eleven billion dollars from the United
States and eight with a combined value
of twenty three point seven billion
dollars by the Chinese two-thirds of the
US investment was in the retail and
commercial consumer sector such as
Walmart coca-cola and others Pepsi and
seventy five percent of the Chinese on
the natural resources and mining sector
the only not exception being the ICBC
and standard Bank investment so the FDI
stop defined by the OECD as the value
investors equity in an net loans to
enterprises was fifty billion dollars
down from a peak of 69 billion dollars
for the United States enterprises which
the peak being in 2014 by comparison the
FDR stock of the Chinese entities in
2017 was 43 billion against the 50 but
up from 16 billion in 2011 so the
trajectory of momentum of Chinese FDI is
increasing whilst debt of the United
States is declining even though it's
higher therefore the US has led F the
FDI African Drive into Africa you know
pretty much resting on its corporations
which fits into the prosper Africa
strategy but China is fast closing in on
USA FDI in Africa lastly on military
activity and support for peace missions
in Africa both countries have one
permanent military base in Africa the
Chinese in Djibouti the United States
has reported 6,500 troops in Africa and
it's reported that there's about two and
a half thousand Chinese troops on peace
missions throughout Africa they've
gained very very difficult to find the
data that's reliable this represents
really tiny military presence in the
overall respective Arsenal's of China in
the United States yet and I found these
statistics
very interesting and quite alarming for
the future of the 226 thousand four
hundred and forty five deaths due to
terrorism globally in 2017 as reported
by the global terrorism database which
is the go-to database in the world on
these matters I understand two-thirds of
all deaths in the world due to terrorism
where in either Middle East North Africa
or sub-saharan Africa two-thirds and
Chinese workers have been a target of
killings and kidnappings in various
countries including Ethiopia and Nigeria
so it appeared to me that if the
negative scenario was to build around
Africa Africa's contribution to
terrorism will grow and the export of
that terrorism is a real risk into the
developed world in summary across these
four categories China has a significant
leader of the United States in
respective African trade is taking the
lead on development financing for from a
more equivalent starting base with the
United States yet the United States
maintains a lead over FDI in Africa even
if the Chinese are closing the gap and
both countries are underweight military
investment in the consonant in
conclusion where does this leave us
the facts presented here of a continent
facing a population explosion amidst
enormous challenges to grow the
economies of Africa should argue paint a
chilling enough picture to be a clarion
call to the world to act now and to act
fast in support of Africa in today's
globally connected world no fortress can
be built around Africa Europe in the
United States as can be seen with 2.1
million African migrants currently in
the United States and ten and a half
million African migrants currently in
Europe are likely to witness growing
incidents of migration terrorism and
conflict on its own soil everything that
can be done to cooperate to lift the
economic development of Africa and its
people should be urgently and
sustainably attended to we
programs in Africa systematically
planned and implemented in all areas
education and Health State
Administration training capacity
building investment aid and market
access infrastructure development job
creation trade support agriculture
industrial development technology and
innovation development finding financing
institutional support intelligence and
policing and military and security no
stone should be left unturned by the
world as great powers and its global
organs to help Africa and the world to
avert a crisis wrought on a continent
plagued by a troubled history
insufficient economic growth too many
people with too little resources Africa
surely needs to lead these efforts but
global support should be aimed at
battering at success at the same time
without sounding the alarm in a negative
way the up to 600 million dollars per
annum growth opportunity on the
continent represents a compelling and
outsized opportunity for investors
wishing to capitalize on this growth and
it's up to those great powers that lead
support for Africa that will optimally
position their own corporates in their
own interests to benefit from that
growth it is both indeed a global threat
and challenge but also a massive
opportunity it is in this light that
discussion of how the world's two
largest economies are and should be
engaging with Africa is so important
each needs to lead with a long-term
strategic response and tactical
interventions should complement not
detract as is the allegation with
respect to ago a qualification from
these long term goals of an African
economy that must grow at a faster rate
than its exploding population and it is
vital to the success of these goals that
China and the United States cooperate as
much as compete in Africa's long-term
interests in this historic mission to
help lift Africa China and the United
States should surely work alongside the
g20 to drive a global plan for Africa's
development as Africa's most developed
nation and it's represent and its
representative on the BRICS alliance and
at the g20 South Africa and the now au
African Union Chairman seroma poser
president Ramaphosa has a special role
to play in driving China United States
and indeed all of the g20 nations to
step up action on Africa and it is to
him that the presidents of the United
States and China should look for
leadership and we BRICS and g20 have
plans that need to be strengthened
resourced and implemented with new
resolve what is clear on the subject of
prosper Africa that as a strategy it is
incomplete at best when compared against
the eight-point China plan it is
relatively under-resourced limited in
scope and narrowly targeted prosper
Africa on its own offers little
confidence that the United States will
arrest its decline relative to China's
rise in importance in Africa this
notwithstanding that the economic
military and political might of the u.s.
gives it a continued enormous influence
and power to change the mix of outcomes
so the United States would be well
advised to look at ways to revise and
prosper and expand prosper Africa and to
strengthen it to take a longer-term view
of the strategic imperatives
relationships and commercial opportunity
and to mobilize the full suite of
institutional technical financial and
corporate resources at its disposal and
those are all extremely considerable in
the United States to optimize its
position for the long term from an
African perspective it wants to have a
plurality of options to seek alliances
and engagements and having multiple
powers the United States China and the
European Union each with its own
strategy plans and resources with which
to engage politically economically
culturally and military is far
preferable for Africa than facing one
dominant power the world needs to be
laid
by Africa and seeking solutions but
humanity cannot fail to rise to this
challenge that by the turn of the
century will directly affect two out of
every five humans on this planet and
indirectly affect everyone thanks very
much speech and you you kind of been
imbued in it a lot of data a lot of
analysis of how things are you know
playing out with regard to China's
positioning on the continent and the
United States so I'll kick off with a
couple of questions and then we'll open
up to the audience to your last point
about kind of African Africa's agency
there is an increased movement now
towards this notion of promoting intra
Africa trade there's the African free
the African free continental trade area
AFC FTA Nigeria and Benin just submitted
their instruments of ratification last
year he was little an idea was one of
the last holdouts and and so the
thinking is I think in my sense that
there's a lot of value that's being lost
in terms of African countries trading
with each other one of the implications
of AFC FTA on this dynamic thanks Eddie
so I think that AFC DEA is a real
opportunity for Africa to grow its trade
with itself to overcome what I refer to
in the longer speech version that you
will get a state state capture of
resources and the migration points or
the immigration points are natural
points of capture you know it's one of
the
tragic jokes of Africa that the best way
to get wealthy is to become the customs
official in the local port and so to the
extent that one can get or get rid of
these friction points right for
corruption it will definitely make a big
difference to the ease of doing business
but it's more than that it's it's it's
really about trying to get the market of
Africa which is 1.2 billion people on to
point six trillion dollars of GDP to
work together rather than it's 54
different countries right and my guess
is the the the free trade agreement will
take a long time to give them if you're
given life so the oxygen that needs to
be provided into the system is important
certainly in South Africa's case the
trade industry Minister Abraham Patel is
pushing very hard the business community
to embrace it and make it work right but
there's a lot of skepticism in the
business environment because every day
they are confronting the friction points
are referred to right right so it's key
is going to take some a lot of time and
effort and commitment from leadership to
be able to actually actualize the true
value of a fc FTA yeah you mentioned
some of the demographic dynamics on the
continent
you know people mentioned that youth
dividend the median age on the continent
is 19 while the rest of the world is
aging immigration is a serious issue we
have a lot of young people dying trying
to cross the Mediterranean what's
amazing to me as well is that there's
young Africans who are making it all the
way to the southern US border with
Mexico through Brazil through you you
know Mexico Guatemala they're getting
all the way there the ambition of the
determination so you have worked a lot
on trying to address this job this issue
youth employment in South Africa one of
the complaints that Africans have had
with the Chinese in the past and this
you know there might be some merit to it
but as some people say it's not quite
the case that the Chinese bring their
own laborers or have a tendency not to
hire and train local labor what is your
sense in terms of how this imbalance it
can be addressed but also the larger
question of youth employment and jobs of
the continent so let me just drift hit
on this Chinese the the question the
perception of the Chinese activities and
then we'll come to the youth question
and I want to add a climate angle great
as well on the position of the Chinese
actually there was some data I came
across where there was perception data
being effectively evaluated across 33
countries in Africa and 63 percent of
the respondents basically rated the
Chinese involvement as favorable highly
favorable or favorable after a barometer
think think so and and and but on the
other hand it's absolutely true that
there are pockets of reaction to the
Chinese investment Zambia's of famous
case were effectively SATA the president
in 2014 I believe was elected on the
back or 2011 was elected on the back of
an anti Chinese platform that followed a
mining or violence at a mine with some
Chinese managers shot some locals in
response to a protest on the mine and
this caused a huge disturbance in Zambia
and caused them to elect SATA actually
we were in the middle at the time of
doing the ginger on materials
transaction which had to get approvals
from the Zambian authorities on the back
of the election of this anti Chinese
president platform so it was rather
complicated so I remember it well but
there are these allegations ambassador
Bolton was very explicit in his prosper
Africa launch that he deemed the Chinese
to be corrupting their dealings in
Africa they all said the same thing just
the other day in Ethiopia right and you
know it's very much part of the
narrative I'm not sure how helpful that
kind of exchange is because it doesn't
create the basis for trust and
cooperation which is essentially what I
am suggesting should be a preferable
route on the youth question you know the
youth in Africa have a real raw deal
because it's a combination of education
and health access there's also the
question of gender-based violence that
my daughter here reminds me of and and
is my conscience about but it's true
that the the the sense of trauma on the
back of post colonialism the civil wars
in Africa and so on is is a real problem
and actually causes migration because
people look for peaceful and secure
environments in which they can bring up
their families and the youth definitely
have a huge amount of of stress and
pressure so in that context business you
know being thoughtful and smart and
proactive is certainly in South Africa's
case what we try to do our co-chair with
investing Stephen cause of the youth
employment service initiative which is
trying to sponsor a million internships
in South African business over a five
year period and we're up to thirty
thousand in the first year so that's
paid internships at the national minimum
wage level but the kids then get an
experience in business and they get a
certificate is certified appraisal which
basically means that they then have
worked and they have got experience and
increases their probability of them
getting jobs in the
significantly so that's an example of an
innovation that is obviously still to be
proven and it's in testing but it's the
kind of thing that needs to happen right
throughout Africa and we just got a at
the moment a lot to deal with in South
Africa and a very negative economic
environment you know projecting 1% and
on the climate change question which
somebody raised with me before I came in
here from Eurasia a company I've just
been appointed a senior adviser to but
he pointed out this this dichotomy that
Africa is really inherited this problem
of the population GDP must match this
this equilibrium I talked about and it's
also layered on top of that got the
worst of the climate change environment
because it's estimated by climate change
experts that Africa is going to be the
center of droughts of water challenges
water problems and a variety of forms of
climate change events which will be very
damaging for the continent and I just
spoke at a class myclass on Ethiopia
where they're building a fifteen
thousand megawatt dam and it's causing
huge amounts of conflict between Sudan
Egypt and Ethiopia as a particular case
in point that could flare up into a
proper conflict and on the other hand
Africa could be as it could be a twenty
four trillion dollar opportunity in the
next - in the next 40 years it could be
a huge experimental ground for climate
change solutions solar energy water of
various forms battery fired power so on
and so forth and so there's this kind of
duality but the stakes are so high in
respect of everything and I must say you
know the population statistics are quite
alarming I mean I think the the
probability of those population
statistics actually becoming true in our
lifetime in other words it's not my
lifetime but it's my son as six years
old he's going to see the end of the
century and he's going to face a
situation where he's living with you
know two fifths of the world being from
Africa you know with a very highly
underweight share of global GDP Thank
You Colin so we'd like to have some
audience participation we have two
roving mics so kindly raise your hand
introduce yourself keep it brief we'll
take three questions at a time hi my
name is Olivia and I'm a student here at
Jackson undergraduate and I'm really
interested in technology investment in
the continent both in the part of China
in the United States you know the most
potent examples being like the bugging
of African Union headquarters or facial
recognition software in Harare do you
think these kind of technological
investments on the continent that are
you know reportedly for the continents
new purpose are ethical
thank you very much hi hi I'm Peter I'm
an undergrad and my question is what is
your assessment of the high-end
manufacturing on the content on the
continent insofar that or relative to
other relatives other countries and to
the rest of the world and so obviously
hi and manufacturing semiconductors this
has been known to produce a lot of
unemployment especially youth employment
or a low low skilled employment and so
what is your assessment of high-end
manufacturing across the continent right
one more question we have so that hand
up there first and come to you next
round yes in the middle at the back
hi I'm from Mozambique and as you may
know the northern provinces are
witnessing a rise of terrorist
activities and president newsy and
President Putin entered into military
contracts upon which Mozambique
contracted private military companies
from Russia which soon found that they
were not able to tackle the terrorist
groups in the north of Mozambique
how does military aid or cooperation
with Mozambique and other African
nations witnessing the rise of terrorism
look like in the future to ensure the
effective response thank you so I am
manufacturing technology extremism and
terrorism
so to Olivia's question on technology I
mean it's a fascinating we could spend
hours on that Olivia and I'm happy for
you to come and see me at the Jackson
Institute room 302
Colin Coleman at yale.edu and you can
talk to me in detail but you know if you
look at the technology the Chinese are
extremely active on the
telecommunication space and one of the
criticisms of prosper Africa or the
suggestions proposal recommendations was
for the American companies to become far
more aggressive with respect to
telecommunications in Africa's there's a
basically a vacuum with who are why well
we what way and then you get and what
ways is applying to Vodacom empty and
all the major companies you know Alibaba
is becoming very very active in Africa
but so is Google so is Amazon so as you
know the data companies are becoming
very active so it's it's actually a very
dynamic environment I would obviously
the the famous example of technology and
its revolution of life in in Africa's
and pacer the Safaricom spin-off that
effectively is now worth
probably one third of the market kappa
Safaricom which is about ten billion
dollars and it's very successful
basically it's mobile payments and it's
very effectively become Africa's most
important fun tech company but it will
in my estimation grow enormously we were
talking today in the class about
Ethiopia's lack of banking basic
competitive banking and very high priced
banks which are as a function of lack of
competition and a student ask the
intelligent question of is it possible
to bring the likes of a stripe to
provide backbone data to banks on
payments and things like that and then
layer in the banks as the sort of
payment the formal payment services come
so there lots and lots of opportunities
I would say if Peter on the
manufacturing side you know I've talked
a lot about Ethiopia but Ethiopia is the
most interesting can't come country from
a strategy point of view because really
what they try to do is position
themselves as the the country that
captures the displacement of old or you
formerly low-cost Chinese labour and
position themselves as the as the
alternative with the Chinese blessing
who are building the infrastructure and
effectively with through export
processing zones and industrial parks
setting themselves up to be the
manufacturers in Africa of low cost jobs
to produce goods that can then be
consumed in other countries including
China itself so they are a very
interesting model of economic
development that really distinguished
themselves but by and large the
industrialization and manufacturing in
Africa is very undeveloped and is one of
the problems that Africa has that it
remains highly dependent on commodity
prices so with this coronavirus you know
if China's economy Falls the Standard
Bank economists for costs a few days ago
that it could shave around one point
2% of sub-saharan Africa growth which is
already under pressure so that you know
that type of that type of of
manufacturing Israeli sorely needed in
Africa I think you were asking from a
different point of view which is the
four IR the fourth Industrial Revolution
impacts on youth the reality is if you
ask about that that there will be a
natural evolution of jobs and the skills
in the economy but actually Africa is a
good place you know for that to happen
because it's not like lots of people are
losing jobs if you can create engine
rooms of production around for I or it
could be additive and then on my friend
from Mozambique you didn't give me your
name but that's a very good question
quite disturbing because you for those
who don't not aware Mozambique has found
what is thought by oil and gas experts
to be the single largest resource of gas
and most high-quality resource of gas
since Qatar this is a 15 billion dollar
GDP country that will spend 50 billion
dollars on the development of this gas
field and I would imagine at the end of
the analysis anybody does the reason
terrorism has flared up in Mozambique is
because of that gas and a fight for
control of that gas in whatever form
since a country that has nothing has
found this huge resource it's now being
managed by ExxonMobil see knock and a
bunch of European oil companies and they
desperately trying to effectively get
their hands on it but what does it mean
I think it's a demonstration that I my
analysis if there's any area that's kind
of a blank canvas it appears to me and
I'm not a military or security expert
I'd love to and I know there lots of
people at Yahoo are I'd love to hear
more about but it appears to me like
it's a relative black blank canvas on
the terrorism and security measures and
yet we have this rise in terrorism in
the Middle East North Africa in
sub-saharan Africa that people seem
quite unaware of so it feels to me like
that
area for interrogation thank you we have
a little bit of time for a few one last
round of questions so the gentleman yeah
gentleman there okay assuming foreign
direct investment like a varies
substantially across so so going forward
with any idea of development on the
continent you is there a danger that
regional differences will become more
exacerbated and lead to issues with
stability across the whole kind of
unequal distribution of growth as things
shape up gentlemen
years ago to the Chinese okay so how do
you compete given the Kenya example for
standard gauge railway yes in the
gentlemen here in the middle of the road
yes hello : this is Thomas man lousy
come from Zimbabwe and my question is
very much centered around what can the
West do for the local industries within
Africa because you noticed that for most
countries within Africa we always end up
experiencing a trade deficit and this
usually comes about because we usually
export our raw materials and when that
finished good thing comes back we're
getting it you know it's a three times
the markup and because of situation like
that it because then becomes hard for us
to meet that six hundred billion dollar
peer growth that you're talking about
that that is necessary sorry you just
want to understand you know how the West
or other countries can position
themselves and actually although helping
the local industries grow and better
function and that way you know possibly
you know stop incurring things like
sanctions and the like start off with
Thomas P and visitors fresh a couple of
things to say the one is actually the
beneficiation issue is one that the
Chinese are accused of but it's the same
when you look at the data between the
Chinese in the United States they both
import raw products and they're both
exports to Africa finished product
in the United States case it's airplanes
and cars so on and so forth in the in
the Chinese case its manufacturing
manufactured goods and so on but they're
importing all the raw materials so and
and any analysis you do it's true so the
question is how do you actually create
industries where there's going to be
beneficiation it's not so much for the
West to do although they could be
helpful it's more about how the local
economies in Africa and the local
business people lead that you know one
of the examples of course is a leaker
dangoty is famous Nigerian who has
effectively watched the importing of
Nigeria's a massive crude producers
produced 2 million barrels of oil a day
but effectively imports refined product
so what is done is he's created for a
about seventeen billion dollar
investment a petrochemical refinery so
he can refine Nigerian crude and sell it
to marketers it's entirely logical and
the question is why they know morally
coding goatees identifying these points
of friction where there's local
materials that is leaving the country
then being imported as a beneficiated
product so it's it's certainly a case I
would say for an opportunity for
businesses locally to examine I know my
daughter's eyes lit up because in my
actual formal speech you'll see there's
reference partly prompted by her to this
question of taxation this question of
share of economic benefit as between a
foreign direct investor and the local
economies and the isness often this
tension places like Zambia Tanzania and
so on and so forth that builds up over a
long period and then these countries do
really nonsensical things to try and
capture back lost economic benefit
through sudden tax like empty and and
Nigeria or in Tanzania a massive you
know five billion dollar tax of beric
operation in the country which is
settled subsequently but it makes a huge
amount of noise but it's all about you
know this question of is there fair
economic distribution but between the
investor in a country and the home
market and home markets get so desperate
for investment that they give up their
taxation requirements that give up their
incentives they give up their equity
shares and so on and so forth and you
know it's very important that there's a
sustainable agreement that's reached
then with respect to Jim I'm going
backwards Jim the funding of that
railway I mean it's a you know obviously
there's international rules the the
unfortunate reality with growing
protectionism and this tension around
breaking the rules by system
in the world which seems to be the
current trajectory of world leaders is
if you had a stronger world rules based
system in the world you'd be able to say
you know to the Chinese you're providing
these interest-free loans and competing
is improper now can we create some
system of fair competition around
provision of financing but if you're an
African country like the DRC and you
have nothing and the Chinese come to you
is happened in 2008 I think and is
approved by the World Bank so they come
to you and they say we'll give you eight
billion dollars of low-cost funding for
your copper mines that otherwise we'll
never get developed will develop them
will provide you the funding and will
take the copper out at preset prices
didn't work out so well by the way for
the Chinese because the copper price
fell significantly and they had a
ratchet so it didn't work out so well
and they tried to renegotiate it but you
know that's if you're the DRC and you
have an option either no funding no
infrastructure no development of your
mind or eight billion dollars from the
Chinese and infrastructure and jobs I
think you know what you're going to
choose so I think the rules-based system
needs to be the guiding principle and
then Paul is a very good question about
regional differences so I mean the the
parameters are used effectively is you
have 54 countries you really have three
big countries and three other countries
the other countries being Kenya Ethiopia
and Angola but you have South Africa
Nigeria and Egypt they the engine rooms
in terms of the size of economies and so
on what you really need for Africa to
rise is for those three countries to
rise now South Africa's engine is
sputtering Nigeria's is arguably not
switched on and Egypt one doesn't know
how long they will have an engine before
things blow up you know so one of the
major issues in my class that we talk
about is how do you
all these engines kind of fire how much
are they gonna fire what's required from
the leaders of the countries how how the
leaders going to navigate their own
political trade-offs in order to get
growth going so in South Africa the
budget has just come out of the Minister
of Finance did an excellent job of
effectively we tried to reset the public
sector wages what does that mean he's
projected 150 billion rand being shaved
off the budget over a three year period
who's his political allies his political
allies on the unions employed in those
public sector companies and in the
government so he's going to have to face
down and ceramikas gonna have to face
down the unions have already reacted to
that budget but there's no alternative
for South Africa but to reform the
fiscal place and to turn away from
consumption into production and to
basically get that productive investment
so the answer is there will be regional
differences absolutely but I'd say watch
those three countries as clues as to
where Africa on aggregate is going but
Africa on aggregate needs to achieve at
least 5% growth rates otherwise the
world is in deep trouble all right
and in the interests of time I think
that's all we can do this evening Colin
thank you very much for very engaging in
all encompassing conversation to the
audience members and the questions thank
you very much Ted Lisa
Maureen thank you for the help putting
this event together and to all of you
for making the time thank you
and that's concludes our event today
[Applause]
[Music]